So in the last decade, there's
been a sudden explosion
in teenage girls
identifying as transgender.
So my book explores why.
Abigail Shrier's "Irreversible Damage:
The Transgender Craze
Seducing Our Daughters"
was one of last year's most
celebrated and condemned books.
It showed up in year-end
lists of top books,
but was also banned by Target.
And her publisher was disallowed
from buying ads on Amazon.
Abigail Shrier's book
is a dangerous polemic
with a goal of making people not trans,
wrote an American Civil Liberties
Union attorney on Twitter.
We have to fight these
ideas which are leading
to the criminalization
of trans life again.
A lawyer by training, Shrier
says she fully supports
the rights of adults to undergo
gender reassignment surgery.
She's concerned that teenage girls
are making irrevocable
changes to their bodies
that in coming years they
might wish they could reverse.
In a new paperback edition
of "Irreversible Damage"
Shrier follows up on several
of the women she spoke with
and details her experiences
of being deplatformed.
Reason spoke with Shrier
about the controversy
over her book, the Streisand effect,
and the future of free expression
in an increasingly polarized
cultural landscape.
Abigail Shrier, thanks
for talking to Reason.
Thank you.
Give me the elevator pitch
for "Irreversible Damage:
The Transgender Craze
Seducing Our Daughters."
So in the last decade, there's
been a sudden explosion
really in teenage girls
identifying as transgender.
We've never seen anything
like this before.
The underlying condition, gender dysphoria
or severe discomfort
in one's biological sex
is something we've known
about for 100 years.
And it always predominantly
afflicted boys and men.
And now in the last
decade, it's overwhelmingly
teenage girls with no childhood
history of gender dysphoria.
So my book explores, why, what's going on?
Why do so many young teenage girls
suddenly decide that they
want to leave womanhood?
And why are so many doctors
and therapists and teachers helping them?
So let's clarify a couple things.
You say historically, the kind of move
to have gender dysphoria or the idea
that you're born in the wrong body
or you're uncomfortable
in the body you're in,
typically that has been mostly
men wanting to be women.
Yes.
Yeah.
Overwhelmingly, I mean the
Do we know why that is?
Or what do people say, why is that?
People have asked me that.
You know, I'm not sure that we do.
There are some attempts to do brain scans
and find neurological
differences, but, you know,
for whatever reason, this did
overwhelmingly afflict boys
and men and so I think there's, you know,
they estimate 0.01% of men
are naturally transgender.
That's what the DSM5
estimated, and for women it's
Which is the manual that
talks about, I mean,
it's the psychological,
psychiatric document of things.
Oh yeah, that's right.
The psychiatric manual,
the DSM5 and for women,
it was 0.003, so you're
talking about tiny,
tiny percentages, one in 30,000 women.
So basically no one you would have gone
to high school with in the last decade.
Now we have more than 2%
of high school students.
Their recent, most recent
surveys are even higher
identifying as transgender.
And we know they're
overwhelmingly teenage girls.
So whenever you see, yeah.
Yeah, I'm sorry, I
didn't mean to interrupt.
No, whenever you see something like that,
it's just worth asking why.
And that's what my book does.
So when you say these are the
overwhelmingly teenage girls
and that it is, you know,
they haven't presented this before.
I have a good friend,
a contributing editor
at "Reason" magazine, Deirdre
McCloskey, who is transgender
and who transitioned in her
50s or around the age of 50.
And she talked about
knowing from the beginning
that she was a woman, even
though she was in a man's body.
I mean, she played football
in college, et cetera.
But what you're talking about are girls
who generally don't have,
or the specific subset
you're talking about are
girls who don't have a history
of always saying, I want to be male.
Yes, that's one of the
peculiar sort of features of it
is that this always
began in early childhood
for those who had it.
It's a real condition.
Right.
And now it's teenage girls
with no childhood history,
meaning they were perfectly comfortable
playing in princess
dresses, never, you know,
very often these girls liked ballet
and all those sort of girly things.
And then they hit their teenage years.
And this is the other peculiar feature,
with their girlfriends
because it very often happens
in peer groups, decide that
they're really transgender
and they start clamoring
for hormones and surgeries.
And unfortunately today they're very,
very easily obtaining them with
almost no medical oversight.